bien depuis le début emmanuel macron et
son gouvernement ont tout fait pour
essayer de contourner le rendez-vous
mocratique jusqu'à cette petite
manoeuvre avec les maires ils
désespéraient sûrement que les maires
leur donne un blanc seing pour reporter
l'échéance démocratique il se trouve que
ça fait exactement l'effet inverse ils
ont eu droit à un effet boomerang à la
part des élus locaux et tout ça me
rassure sur des questions de principe je
sais que nos concitoyens c'est parfois
un peu curieux dans cette période de
voir des politiques monté au créneau
pour défendre des rendez vous électoraux
souvent les citoyens au 10 mai vous
occuper de vos affaires électorales non
on s'occupe des affaires démocratique
est dans une période où tous les
principes s'efface peu à peu
principe de liberté les principes de
démocratie c'est capital de tenir bon
sur des rendez vous démocratique qui
sont des questions de principes
démocratiques et républicains
belle ambition la droite républicaine
c'est de rassembler les français si
cette ambition gaulliste c'est un défi
magnifique et donc moi je suis de ceux
qui veulent rassembler les français pas
assez les murs alors oui pousser les
murs en tous les cas faire en sorte que
nos valeurs soient celles qui portent un
espoir pour les français
on peut toujours se rassurer en étant
toujours les mêmes entre nous ce qu'il
faut c'est que nous allions ou delà de
notre famille politique